so yesterday a day before presiding over
a joint session of congress to
confirm the victory of joe biden as the
next president of the united states
uh joe by uh mike pence rather vice
president mike pence
met with donald trump and reportedly
told him
i can't overturn the election results
donald trump has been increasingly
pointing to mike pence saying we've got
to count on mike pence mike pence has to
come through for us
and that's code four figure out a way to
steal an election that we actually
didn't win
and the new york times is now reporting
that mike pence quote tried to lower the
president's expectations
while seeking ways to mollify him
this is an article by annie carney and
maggie haberman where they say vice
president mike pence
told trump on tuesday that he didn't
believe he had the power
to block congressional certification of
joe biden's win
in the presidential election which is
true he doesn't despite trump's baseless
insistence that he did and this is
according to multiple people
a briefed on the content of the
conversation this took place during the
weekly lunch
that mike pence has with donald trump
and
this was just hours after trump started
publicly pressuring
uh mike pence to essentially
steal the election for him i mean we we
have to call things what they are and
these euphemisms about
making sure all legal votes are counted
we have the election results in every
state
those results have been certified the
electors have then certified their votes
and today and it may be happening as we
speak
it may be done by the time you listen to
today's show or watch this clip
the joint session of the house and
senate is counting those
votes trump tweeted the president has
the power to reject fraudulently chosen
electors
and of course it is not true that there
were fraudulently chosen electors
none of this is true and most
importantly
mike pence cannot alter the results
mike pence can hear objections from
senators and
members of the house which we expect to
hear there can be debate about that
we heard that tim scott and james inhofe
two radical right senators are
uh saying that they will not be
participating in these attempts to
undermine the results but reportedly 11
or 12 republican senators
are going to so there's a few different
aspects to this
number one january 20th really couldn't
get here any faster
we're down to exactly two weeks um two
weeks to the day
joe biden will be getting sworn in and
trump will be
we don't know where and i'll talk
actually about that a little bit later
i would love to have been a fly on the
wall during the conversation
where pence is explaining to trump i
can't just alter the results
i can't just declare ourselves i can't
declare you and i
the winners i just can't do it how was
trump reacting during that conversation
was he furious was he resigned was he
sad was he mopey trump
and then even after this conversation
took place where mike pence told trump i
can't do the thing you want me to do
trump insisted on twitter that he can
again trump tweeting we looked at this
tweet earlier
if vice president mike pence comes
through
for us we will win the presidency
many states want to decertify the
mistake they made
in certifying incorrect and even
fraudulent numbers in a process not
approved by their state legislatures
which it must be
mike can send it back and he can't
so let's do kind of a gut check
consider how insane it is that this is
something that happened
the president is told by the vice
president i can't steal the election
and it's newsworthy it is newsworthy
because that is exactly what the
president wants the vice president to do
things are so nutty that it is actually
noteworthy
that a vice president had to sit the
president down and talk to him
like a big boy and say i can't steal the
election
for you now as a reminder the line of
reasoning that it takes to assume
mike pence can do this is that mike
pence as the
presiding officer of this joint session
to count electoral votes
can say i am going to ignore certain
electoral votes
as decided by the states oh the
pennsylvania electoral votes i'm going
to ignore them we're not going to count
those
and there's this alternate slate of
electors which is just random people
it's not there's nothing legally binding
i'm going to accept as an
alternate slate of electors these 20
republicans who showed up and did
something of no legally binding uh
importance and said we vote for trump
pence doesn't have the power to do that
and a number of interesting um
procedural and congressional law
experts over the last few days have
given interviews to that effect
i'm not bothering to play them because i
think most of my audience
understands that trump's dying words
really may be
we totally won georgia we totally won
pennsylvania in 2020.
he may repeat that to his dying day but
trump's leaving in two weeks
and the concern of course is how are the
trump cultists going to react
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical